Let's start the session. Thank you for coming to the session,
Dissecting Hematologic Malignancies at Single-Cell
Resolution in Spatial Omics.
This session will be chaired by me.
My name is Mamiko Sakata-Yanagimoto, University of Tsukuba,
Japan.
Hematologic malignancies, the tumor
growth is supported by a complex interaction between
tumor cells and the microenvironmental immune cells
and stromal cells.
So in this session, we will discuss how spatial analysis
will visualize and dissect the
microenvironments of hematologic malignancies,
especially focusing on lymphoma.
So today, we'll have three speakers.
The first speaker will be Dr. Rong Fang, Yale University.
So Rong, please start your presentation.
All right.
Okay. Thank you for kind of staying around for the last day
of the AACR. And so what I'm going to talk to you
today
is, I call lymphoma transformers, because of my
close collaborator, literally, the kind of
co-PI driving the entire project, Mina Sue, and she loves
Transformers so much.
And so, okay, now,
the story is about the transformation of lymphoma from
low-grade or indolent to higher grade or
often large B-cell lymphoma. But they're kind of like transformers.
We try to catch them in a space. All right.
And so this is my disclaimer. And so again, Mina,
and I was really inspired by her vision,
also sometime her
demanding questions. One is,
"You can do the spatial transcriptome and
protein and the spatial epigenomics, and can you really look
at the same tissue I'm examining every day
for diagnosis of patients, right?
And so often, those tissue specimens are in paraffin
blocks, and can you really make your spatial omics sequencing
fully compatible with FFPE tissue blocks?"
And so I think that's a kind of good
question for us to think about as technology innovator,
but that also
kind of reflects the desire by our pathologists to learn
much better molecular information and really help our patients.
So over the past ten years, we have witnessed the emergence of the whole
field called spatial omics,
and
twinned the
spatial RNA profiling called spatial transcriptomics, which was chosen
as the Method of the Year by Nature Methods.
And two very nice review articles written by Professor
Xiaowei Zha and Professor Joakim Lönnerberg,
pointing out two distinct approaches towards spatial transcriptomics.
One is by imaging, the other is high-throughput NGO
sequencing. And we were probably among the first groups
thinking, "Ah, can we do beyond just the
RNA transcriptomics?" And really venturing
into multi-omics across the central dogma of molecular
biology. And so in recent years, they've become even more
exciting. For example,
Professor Matthias Mann, Max Planck Institute, developed
the Divap, which is one of the few examples nowadays you can do
kind of unbiased
proteomics using mass specs. And now you have other tools, not just the imaging,
NGO sequencing, also have mass spec in
play for spatial omics. And also, can
you connect the omics to
functions, for example, metabolic activities?
We have been interested in this question for years, and
our approach is the collaboration with my colleague,
my friend here, Lin Ye, UC San Diego,
utilizing optical chemical imaging such as
stimulated Raman scattering microscopy to map out different
metabolic activities. In the same tissue, we can do protein
RNA or epigenome, and you can truly connect the omics
to what the cells are actually doing.
And
so this is kind of a roadmap of the sequencing-based
spatial omics. I don't want to
go into the details, but
the beginning of this journey is really the landmark
paper published by Professor Joakim Lönnerberg back 2016,
using DNA microarray to capture transcripts, and now that's 10X
Genomics. And so we came up with a somewhat kind of opposite
approach. Instead of capturing within the DNA barcodes into the tissue,
such that we can barcode transcripts, proteins, but also
epigenetic features.
So we demonstrate the pretty kind of
diverse applications of this spatial
deterministic barcoding to look at,
in particular, spatial epigenomics and also spatial multi-omics,
including chromatin accessibility, histone modifications.
And recently, my former post-doc now a professor at Penn,
further demonstrated you can also map out DNA methylome
spot by spot across the entire tissue as well.
Okay, back to RNA. And as I mentioned, I think that's the
beginning.Of this
revolution of spatial omics and
RNA or transcriptome remains to some degree, still
in the mainstay of the whole technology landscape.
But if you Google, or now you have better tools,
ChatGPT or Gemini, to ask, "Okay, what is spatial transcriptomics?"
Basically, two keywords. One is RNA, and the other, of course,
spatial, but not much about
what type of RNA, just RNA expression.
But if you're a molecular biologist, you know
that's not a full story at all. And actually, even the
same messenger RNA molecule has such a dynamic life
cycle, starting from transcription to the further
maturation to different isoforms, and some going to give you the proteins, and
then the degradation. This process is tightly regulated by
many non-coding RNAs, actually, that constitutes
95 or even more than 95% of the RNA molecules.
And unfortunately, most of the spatial transcriptomics technologies do not tell you
anything about that.
I really think that they are the most important part of RNA biology,
but the expression of different messenger RNA transcripts are largely just the
outcomes.
Then we started to ask, can we
look at all kinds of RNA
molecules and understand this RNA regulation,
RNA regulatory network, but in a tissue Mina looking at every
day? The FFPE tissue block for clinical
diagnosis. And so the little trick we came up with
was actually originally
developed by Professor Steve Quake.
Instead of you capture messenger RNAs based
on their own endogenous polytail, you can use an
enzyme to add a polytail to whatever RNA
molecules, RNA species, but also to the fragment of RNA.
In that context, turns out that's a good thing, even if
in FFPE, the RNA molecules are very
fragmented, and you can add many polytail to those
short fragments. As a result, you'll actually get an even better detection
sensitivity compared to fresh frozen tissue spatial
transcriptome.
But what's more exciting
for
the study of RNA biology is now you can see many different RNA species, not
limited to
protein coding
messenger RNAs anymore. So now you see
link RNA, microRNA, and tRNA, and
snoRNA, sRNA, and so on and so forth.
And for example, tRNA can further
quantify the different amino acids associated with tRNA that
very specific amino acid associated tRNA.
Now you can see spatially they are different.
And probably no one ever noticed this because no tool existed in the
past to allow you to map out the tRNA distribution at this
resolution. It turns out tRNA is the first
small non-coding RNA discovered and recognized by
Nobel Prize. And so back to the
key
topic and the core topic I want to discuss today,
lymphoma transformers. So
I've taken the clinical tissue specimens, as I alluded
before, and performed this type of spatial total RNA
sequencing. This is a patient who suffer from stomach for
two months and no clear reason came to
Yale, and a couple of biopsies taken from
the stomach, and Mina look at the tissue specimens.
And her diagnosis
by looking at the histology is, okay, the one on
top probably
already lymphoma, but relatively benign, and the one on the bottom
has a lot of large B cells, probably already diffused large B cells, but from
the same patient. And that might really indicate
a transformation from this low-grade lymphoma
to diffused large B-cell lymphoma.
And so it actually took a lot more than just looking
at that histology image to do diagnosis.
Mina order a lot of molecular
pathology tests,
and up to 10 different IHC and a gene arrangement test.
Altogether, actually, it's pretty expensive, and also take
quite a bit of time to get the results back to give definitive
diagnosis. It's a relatively easy case.
If that's a complicated, tricky diagnosis,
it's probably taking even much longer time, and still
without sufficient molecular information, you cannot make a
diagnosis at all. That does happen pretty often.
So in this patient, if
you need to treat, there's still a standard R-CHOP, but some
patients might respond to PI3K inhibitor, but we don't know who's going to
respond, who cannot. And we took this
sample and performed this spatial total RNA sequencing called a
PathoDB, and very nice spatial clusters you can see.
And
by
annotating a gene
expression profile associated with the clusters, you can already see the
dominant cell types in each of those tissue regions.
However, what is very powerful nowadays, given the
latest advances in computational biology and
AI modeling, now we're able to integrate
seamlessly with the high-resolution H&E, such that
you canTurn this H&E into this colorful
spatial molecular profile and almost single-cell resolution,
not exactly but close, using the computational method developed
by Professor Mingiao Li at Penn called iSTAR.
And so now I get much more granular cell types
by combining the information from the molecular and also
from the
tissue and the cell morphology or even subnuclear
morphology. And
we're doing the same thing for the diffuse large B-cell
lymphoma biopsy from the same patient. Now we can ask a lot of questions.
And for example, the
tumor cells themselves, but you can also ask the question about other cell
types in a, since this is in situ spatial, for example,
we were asking a macrophage in the
low grade versus on the high grade, what's the difference?
And we notice indeed in diffuse large B-cell lymphoma is a
macrophage polarized more or less to M2.
And also you see a lot of interesting metabolic pathways you would never
suspect and notice. And then now we got all those mapped out in this
unbiased genomic spatial total RNA
sequencing. And so recently we further developed even more
powerful AI-enabled tool to integrate them together to
give you a truly single-cell resolve, as you appreciate from this
image, in particular, in the enlarged view, it's a truly cell-by-cell,
single-cell spatial total RNA transcript, and you can derive
by combining the images and the spatial transcript
on total RNA sequencing.
So for cancer, and you'll get to understand or
at least look into the genomic alterations, including the copy number
variation, the single nucleotide variants.
And the latter has been very difficult to decode de novo at a
genome scale. And largely because in the past people
sequenced this, a very short fragment from the three prime end, you don't have
sufficient coverage to do unbiased genomic
calling of SNV. But in our cases, even though this
is now a long read, but we do get a full coverage
across the whole length of RNA. And then we ask, "Hey, can you
do de novo calling of SNV?" It turns out that
worked out pretty well, but I don't want to say that trivial.
There's a lot of computational,
we need to
come up, we need to develop. And now you see the SNV count high
rating corresponds in the tumor, and this relatively
easy case further confirmed by Mina using the standard
IHC staining. But if you don't know, I would say the genomic changes should
be your gold standard, should be your ground truth to call the malignant
versus non-malignant. Also, since there's a whole genome scale,
SNV profile can take the profile to do a
further clustering, and then you can see where they are.
So that's
what's super cool in this type of data.
And you can further look into
sort of this
tumor evolutionary phylogenetic tree, but
mapped out where the different clones in a spatial context.
So now I can see the
most
sort of high SNV count
clones actually have multiple different clones spatially segregated in
different regions.
You can also look into the specific mutations, and we
have no kind of prior knowledge which matters, which not, and
interestingly, we found one. And then we look back to the
literature and we found, wow,
Ari Melnick, a couple years ago, demonstrate this mutation
actually can drive the extranodal lymphoma
proliferation by inducing more kind of memory-like
phenotype. So that's cool, and now we see
that happens, that occur in this patient.
All right. And so another
important advantage of this technology can look at not
just
protein coding transcripts. As I mentioned,
more than 95% of the transcripts are non-coding.
And this is from our data, you can see the coding
rates
still 60% to 70%, but because they are in
general longer.
However, we do get a sufficient number of rates corresponding
to various non-coding RNA species.
What is most difficult to detect, that's a microRNA, because they are
extremely short and
alsoOften kind of embedding the
protein.
But it turns out this approach worked out reasonably well.
And if you study microRNA, in human cells, we
have a little over 2,000 microRNA.
From this data, we detect 1,800 approaching
the whole pool of the microRNA.
For microRNA, each microRNA has been
kind of annotated and also computational, that you
can predict which ones are their target genes and
also upstream of each microRNA, which genes might
regulate the biogenesis and the function of that
microRNA. So now we can look at, first of all, different
microRNA differential expression since this spatial resolved
data. You can ask, "Oh, which ones are upregulated in the tumor,
downregulated in the tumor?" Or as I mentioned, in different tumor clones,
right, which ones are upregulated in different tumor clones?
You can ask all kinds of questions you are interested in.
The data extremely informative.
But afterwards, for example, we saw
miR-21, which is one of the well-characterized
oncomirra. That makes perfect sense, and the other is
miR-155. We don't exactly know what the function of that might be.
But as I mentioned, you have the target genes you can
predict. You have the genes upstream you can predict, but now we have
real data. Okay, you can see upstream which genes are
actually detected and downstream which ones are actually detected,
and you take those ones you actually detected to perform gene ontology
analysis. You'll figure out, "Oh, wow, that's exactly what happened."
And upstream, that's sort of PI3K pathway
activation based on most of the genes enriched for that
pathway. And that corresponds to persistent
chronic inflammation
and then activates miR-155, and then
miR-155 further upregulate
the activation. For upregulating the activation of
PI3K/AKT pathway. So, as I
mentioned before, I think some patients
might respond to PI3K inhibitor but it turns out that's a very
toxic drug and often you don't want to use
without knowing this patient might benefit.
And from this data, we suspect this patient actually might benefit, and
this mirror, this microRNA, potentially can serve as a biomarker to
stratify the patient for the targeted therapy.
That's how I imagine this type of data can actually inform
the precision medicine in individual patients.
So this work has been published and also chosen on the cover on
"Molecular Biology." I wasn't
very clear why, but later I said, "Oh, actually first time you can see such rich
molecular biology in clinical FLT tissue specimens."
A little bit, kind of couple of more small
examples to show the transformers.
And so recently,
as I mentioned, there are two distinct approach towards spatial omics.
One by imaging, the other by sequencing.
We're asking, "Can we combine both and you get a best of
both worlds?" Because I think if you really want
to get a single-cell or subcellular
mapping, you've got to go to imaging, that's the best.
But if you want to have unbiased base-by-base sequencing to do
de novo genome-wide discovery. So there are two definitions of resolution.
One is spatial resolution and the other genome resolution, right?
So sequencing gives you the ultimate genome resolution at
a single-base level. But if you combine both
even though the different modality, but if we can do both on the same tissue,
computationally integrate them together, you may get the best out of
both worlds. So that was published a couple of months ago in
"Nature Methods," but even though that's "Nature Methods" paper,
we apply this to various
human lymphoma transformations.
This is the marginal zone lymphoma.
So actually in the same tissue you can see some region
already manifest as diffuse large B-cell lymphoma.
After this DIBER+ protocol, we can
turn every spot
into a single-cell transcriptome.
And now we can perform this kind of U map and
also the pseudo-time trajectory analysis at a single-cell
level. So on the right, the dot by dot, they are from
single-cell transcriptome now.
So another is Richter transformation.
Basically, the chronic lymphoblastic leukemia
can transform into DLBCL. And so that
transformation can be seen, I think, in this interesting
sample. You see particular region that's still a cell,
and majority of the tissue is DLBCL, but you also have a
lot of cells in the DLBCL regions
requiring this DIBER+ protocol to
deconvolve and to give rise to truly single-cell resolution,
spatial by single-cell transcriptome.
So we did that and got on a single-cell transcriptome, but each
cell we know where they are. And now you perform the clustering,
you see very distinctive separation between large and the small
B-cell lymphomas,
which is very different from the marginal zone...
lymphoma transformation. However, when you're looking at small cells in
this case, so it turns out they are not homogeneous, and the small
cells in a different region already manifest some
phenotypic change. And then you take them to perform in real time, you can
actually see how they gradually change themselves step by step
towards finally transforming into diffuse large B-cell lymphoma.
As I mentioned, we're able to look at
not just the protein coding, but also non-coding RNAs.
And we show in this
lymphoma, large versus small cell, and also different regions
of the small cell, now we can identify the microRNAs that might be
associated with the lymphoma transformation. All right.
So probably I'm going to stop here. I have a few slides to show.
You can also look at this at epigenetic, but I'm going to skip that for
maybe ACR next year.
All right. I just want to use this slide to summarize.
I think the spatial omics now is
much more advanced with both the
resolutions, okay. We talk about resolution a lot, but I would say there are
two resolutions. Okay. Now, by combining
multi-modality, multi-omics approaches,
and also empowered by AI, now we can
generate the same tissue Amina looking at every day.
Now I get a single-cell resolve, all kinds of molecular information, at
least across all different RNA species, to really empower
our
clinical pathology practice in the future.
I would like to conclude by thanking my former and current
lab members and all amazing collaborator funding support, in particular
for this grant, and part of the
NCI H10 consortium and also the Lymphoma
FL, supported by Mark Foundation and the Follicular Lymphoma
Foundation. Thank you very much for your attention.
Thank you, Rong. So are there any questions from the audience?
So please identify yourself.
Hi. Ian Market from Barcelona. Thank you for your talk.
It's amazing.
I saw in the last slide that you mentioned that you can capture B-cell
receptor and T-cell receptor data, but how's
your experience with this kind of
data in this
technology?
Yeah.
So, I think Professor Joakim Lundeberg
published a paper about spatial VDJ.
And so I think
it has this unique
advantage, even without doing long reads,
technically no way to do long reads since that's paraffin tissue specimens.
But we do see
a pretty decent amount of
TCR/BCRs we can detect. But now,
for given sequencing depth, we want to detect everything, right?
And then the number of TCR/BCR reads are really low,
still pretty low.
However, we have been talking to Joakim,
actually we can use the same approach they developed, published in their science
paper, to enrich the TCR/BCR sequence before
you do the sequencing. But you don't have to change
everything upstream. Just once you get a PCR amplicon, you can
do another round of enrichment. I believe that should give you a much
better coverage for immune repertoire.
We haven't done that, but that should be durable.
Go ahead.
Hi, I'm Eric. I'm from BC Cancer in Vancouver.
So,
excellent talk. I really enjoyed it.
Mm-hmm.
There was one particular slide that kind of interested me, was the tRNA stuff that
you can detect, and there you were able to detect spatial
distributions of tRNA,
non-coding
RNA, et cetera.
I just want to ask, so did you find anything in regards of
differential spatial distributions between,
let's say, lymphomas that transform and don't transform?
I was interested in, did you find any
biological results that reflect or are predictive or prognostic of
transformation? Yeah. Thank you.
Yeah. I think from the same tissue or just a couple of those, we already
identified some of those, but I think that requires further validation
across a very large number of specimens, large number of patients.
And so,
I have a few there. I just keep those slides.
If you look at all those kind of differential volcano plots, the
top rank, those are the ones we identify.
And so a lot of interesting program, including the
metabolism I didn't
talk about. I think
associated with the transformation, you'd also see a significant
alteration in the metabolic
program. And
often, I don't know why, that was kind of always among the
top-rank programs. And we also
use the metabolic chemical
imaging to not just verify, actually discover what happens in
terms of iNL. And very interestingly, we noticed some
either nuclear or perinuclear lipid droplets
that give you a dramatic change during the transformation to
diffuse large B-cell lymphoma, whether or not it's targetable and how to target.
I think no one ever thought about this kind of lipids in lymphoma.
Yeah.
Dr. C, yeah.
Can I ask you one question right here at the table?
Okay.
Okay, thanks. It was a fantastic talk.
Thank you.
In the case of where you had the Richter transformation and the CLL-
Mm-hmm
... in the same tissue, were you able to look at
proliferation centers in the low-grade part of it and see
were they related... more closely related
just to the small cells, so that you could see where your
cells in the proliferation center and the small center would be cycling back and
forth, and there's something just drastically different about the Richter.
Or could you see things similar in the proliferation center that you could
point to that that's where the Richter came from?
Oh, you are totally right. So that's when we take all the
small cells.
And they are
in a rich cell region in that tissue, but also in
a
DLBCL region, you also see a lot of those kind of
small cells. And then since now
that becomes single-cell resolved, and we take those cells and compare to the ones
still in the, that you call proliferating center,
they are different. But there's not a distinctive difference.
That's actually a continuum. That's when we
take all those cells and plot as a kind of shorter time.
Now you see the whole continuum within the small cells.
Yeah, that's exactly that got our attention.
We just look at all the small cells, and we saw the
gradual shift. By a certain point, that's still what I
suspect, because the separation between the small and the large cells
is dramatic, and at a certain point, they're going to make that big
jump into large cell phenotype.
So may I have one question to you?
Sure.
Dr. Wei, it is quite impressive that the spatial
biology analysis can be applicable to clinics.
So my question is, if I give back the patients their
sequencing data, we do a deep sequencing, more than
sometimes thousands of sequencing to
ensure the accuracy. So how about
that? It is quite similar to the TCR B cell sequencing question.
Yeah. I think it's slightly different from TCR
B cell, because we can do better, we just haven't
done better. We haven't taken that approach to get better
data.
But back to just the RNA gene expression,
I think now,
so data analysis and from data to insights.
Okay, first of all, that might take,
nowadays, there's a huge amount of time and effort by our computational
guys. And how to really
change that in a clinical practice,
maybe going to be done by agent in the future. That's one.
Number two,
I think the assay itself, nowadays, still academic
prototype and how to
really not just scale, but really
industrialize everything. Just in a path we have to
go through,
but we need to have a good case to show it's necessary.
It provides
critical additional information really needed
for accurate diagnosis as compared to the standard, for example,
FoundationOne. I've been talking about FoundationOne a lot.
And so you got to show this is
critical additional information beyond the FoundationOne.
Yeah, I do have a few cases I'm
thinking we can really pursue of spatial
genome testing in a clinical.
Yeah.
It's interesting. So are there any questions? No?
So thank you, Rong.
Thank
you.
Oh. This is different.
Hello. So I'm talking. My name is Mamiko Sakata-Yanagimoto,
University of Tsukuba. My title today is Spatial
Multi-omics Dissects Immune and Stromal Cell Heterogeneity in
T-cell Lymphoma. And it is a great honor for me to have
been invited to talk here today.
Here is my COI disclosure.
So already, Rong greatly have a nice talk.
Lymphoma tissues are consisted of not only
tumor cells, but also a rich variety of stromal and
immune cells.
Sorry.
So we have elucidated lymphoma
pathophysiology by clarifying the lymphoma
microenvironments.
And now by using spatial multi-omics, it is a powerful
tool for delineating the microenvironments of lymphoma.
So by using single-cell analysis, we constructed
single-cell analysis atlas of stromal diversity in
human lymph nodes in 2022.
And now, by using spatial transcriptomics, we could
identify spatial distribution of diverse stromal
cells in human lymph nodes at single-cell resolution.
And this approach is, of course, applicable to understand the
lymphoma microenvironments.
We captured whole T-cell architectures in follicular
lymphoma in this study.
Firstly, we identified novel T-cell subsets using
single-cell RNA sequencing, TCR sequencing,
and then we identified these spatial distribution by
spatial transcriptomicsAnd we further identified their
prognostic impact by using multiplex digital
spatial profiling
for more than 240 follicular lymphoma cases.
So today, my role is covering the spatial
transcriptomics in T and NK cell neoplasms.
So firstly, I will provide a brief overview, and
then I will talk about our original data regarding
vascular niches in angioimmunoblastic T-cell lymphoma by
spatial transcriptomics.
So I will start from this topic.
T and NK cell neoplasms are consisted of up to
34 subtypes,
and there are many epigenetic risks are known.
For example, chronic infection by EBV virus for
NK/TTL,
HTLV-1 for ATLL, and germline
variants, and clonal hematopoiesis are known to be the risk
for T-cell lymphoma development.
And most subtypes are known to have poorer prognosis like this.
And until today, there is a series of published
spatial analysis regarding T and T cell lymphomas.
These cover three major subtypes:
extranodal NK/TTL, angioimmunoblastic
T-cell lymphoma, AITL, and mycosis
fungoides and cutaneous T-cell lymphoma, CTCL.
Most published studies are published in these
two years, 2024 or '25,
using multiple platforms including Xenium, GeoMX,
Visium, CODEX, CosMX, and so forth.
And across these major subtypes,
shared features and distinct features are
discovered. For example, shared TMA features
include tumor-associated macrophages,
cancer-associated fibroblast remodeling,
and CD8 T-cell exhaustion, as well as Treg.
And as an example of a distinct feature,
TLS formation has been known to
be
found during the progression of CTCL development.
Then I will talk about our recent data about vascular
niches in AITL by spatial transcriptomics.
I will
introduce you about AITL.
AITL is an intractable lymphoma with a five-year
overall survival of 35%.
It is the most common T-cell lymphoma worldwide,
predominantly affecting elderly individuals.
AITL patients display lymphadenopathy, high
fever, and skin rash, as well as autoimmune-like
manifestations.
Pathologically, AITL tumor cells mimic T follicular
helper cells.
And as
the name angioimmunoblastic T-cell lymphoma,
the proliferation of vascular vessels and
EBV sometimes infected immune cells,
especially immunoblasts, are the hallmark of the disease.
So firstly, I will talk about immunoblasts in AITL.
AITL genome has three characteristic features.
Epigenetic mutations, including TET2 and
DMT3A, RHOA mutation, and
T-cell receptor signaling pathway mutations.
And notably, most of TET2 and some
DMT3A mutations come from clonal hematopoiesis.
So AITL is a representative cancer derived from
clonal hematopoiesis.
Based on the gene mutation distribution pattern, we have
raised the concept multi-step tumor genesis in
AITL development.
Firstly, hematopoietic stem cells acquire TET2
mutation during the aging process and evolve into
premalignant cells.
The tumor-specific RHOA mutations instruct these cells
into AITL tumor cells,
and simultaneously, AITL premalignant
cells can be differentiated into various inflammatory cells
and infiltrated into tumor tissues.
So in the AITL tissues, the tumor cells have
TET2 and RHOA mutations, while inflammatory
cells have TET2 mutations alone.
So we hypothesize that TET2-mutated inflammatory cells
function as a niche to support tumor cells.
By using a single-cell approach, combining with mouse data,
we
propose that TET2-mutated germinal center B cells
have both light zone and dark zone properties
simultaneously, and it function as a niche to
support AITL tumor cells in both human and
model mouse tumor through CD40
ligand/CD40 axis.
Then I will focus on proliferation of vascular
system in AITL.
As I have mentioned, hyperproliferation of blood cells
is the origin of the disease name,
and tumor cells are known to exist alongside blood
vessels.And the blood vessels have been thought
to be high endothelial venules, HEV.
So we have research questions.
Are there any heterogeneities of blood vessels in
AITL
and do they function as microenvironmental cells to support
tumor cells?
Before we address this question, we performed
single-cell analysis to clarify the heterogeneity of
blood endothelial cells in human lymph nodes.
Before the single-cell RNA sequencing era, only three
subtypes of BEC are known:
artery, vein, and high endothelial
venule.
However, by using single-cell RNA sequencing,
we identified 10 subclusters including TIP cells,
essential for angiogenesis,
and HEV, high endothelial venules, can be
sub-classified into four subtypes.
So to capture the AITL BEC
heterogeneity, we performed single-cell spatial
multi-omics analysis on BEC in human AITL.
We analyzed 189 AIT samples in
total by using single-cell RNA sequencing,
spatial multi-omics including spatial transcriptomics,
and multiplex digital spatial profiling.
Firstly, I have to explain about single-cell RNA
sequencing data.
By using single-cell RNA sequencing, we profiled
more than 50,000 cells like this for
normal and AIT samples.
And consistent with pathological findings,
BECs were increased in AIT samples.
Unsupervised clustering with single-cell RNA sequencing data
identified 10 BEC subclusters.
And notably,
transitional capillary activated
HEV comprised two subclusters,
chHEV1 and chHEV2.
And by using pseudo-time analysis, both
chHEV subtypes were post-capillary
states differentiated from tBEC from here like
this.
And by checking the subclusters of
BEC of AIT and normal samples, we found
that proportion of chHEV2 and TIP
cell, tBEC, was significantly in AITL
comparing to control.
And by using differential gene expression analysis,
we found that both chHEV in AITL
exhibited elevated expression of integrin-related genes.
Then to characterize the spatial distribution of these
subclusters of BEC in AITL,
we performed single-cell transcriptomics using Xenium in
situ.
We constructed two panels, custom panels containing
289 genes designed by top markers
of subclusters of single-cell RNA sequencing data,
and the prefixed 5K panel, including
500 additional gene panels.
We used custom panel to analyze discovery cohort
samples and prefixed 5K panel to analyze
validation cohort samples.
We finally found that spatial transcriptomics by Xenium in
situ identified lumen-like vasculature structure in
AIT samples.
By using a clustering of cells based on Xenium in
situ data, all 10 BEC
subclusters and multiple immune cell clusters
found by single-cell RNA sequencing were successfully
identified like this.
Then we mapped these subclusters onto the H&E specimen
like this.
So we found that a spatial transcriptomics
analysis
could identify individual blood cells composed of multiple
BEC subclusters.
In the left figure shows that the tumor density high
area is colored by yellow, the tumor low
density area is colored by blue,
and each BEC subcluster is
color-coded as follows. Artery
subcluster with a red color,
HEV in yellow, and veinous
subcluster in green or blue.
So we could find that in the
tumor density high region,
HEV yellow color are very
enriched like this.
And then we calculated the distance between tumor dense region
and each BEC subcluster,
and we found that chHEV1, was a
capillary activated HEV, was closest to
regions with high tumor density area.
Then we performed neighborhood analysis to identify
tumor supportive niches.
Here, we show the proportion of tumor cells as
follows.We could identify three
niches:
GCB niche, T cell-enriched niche, and
cHEV FDC niche.
The GCB-enriched niche was consistent with our previous
finding that AITL tumor cells having T
follicle helper features are supported by clonal
hematopoiesis-derived TET2-mutated GCB cells.
GCB niche are shown on the specimen like this.
And the cHEV FDC niche is a
novel finding. We identified a novel niche
containing cHEV1,
FDC,
and of course, tumor cells.
And this niche was characterized by selective enrichment of
exhausted T
cells.
And in this figure, black dots showing
exhausted T cells are enriched in cHEV
FDC niche comparing to artery or
HEV niche.
And in this graph, shows that exhausted T cell
density was higher in cHEV FDC niche
comparing to artery or HEV niche.
So to validate these
findings by protein expression, we performed
multiplex digital spatial profiling using 40
antibodies, again designed by single-cell
data, top markers of single-cell RNA sequencing
subclusters for more than 120
samples.
Combining these markers successfully delineated
multiple BEC subclusters, including
artery, capillary, cHEV,
HEV, and vein.
And this is the data showing the clustering, and
then we mapped this cluster onto the specimen like this.
We successfully identified the spatial distribution of 10
immune and six VE subclusters onto the
specimen of a
phenocyclofusion multiplex digital spatial profiling data like
this.
And in this left figure shows that white arrows
indicate cHEV expressing
PEVAP and MECA-79
simultaneously.
And the purple
cells indicate TIM-3 expressing
exhausted T cells.
So as shown in this figure, exhausted T cells
preferentially accumulated around regions enriched with
cHEV.
And then we calculated peri-vascular index,
indicating the enrichment of specific immune cell
populations around each BEC subtype.
We found that the PVI of exhausted T
cells was highest
around cHEV1.
cHEV1 is this.
Then we checked the cHEV signature and the
clinical outcome.
In the left graph shows that PVI of
exhausted T cells around cHEV1 was
significantly higher in non-responder groups
comparing to responder groups,
while PVI of cytotoxic T cells was
comparable between non-responder and responder.
And by using the analysis of RNA sequencing
published data, we found that patients with high
expression cHEV and HEV signature had a
worse clinical outcome.
Here are the summary of my talk today.
Single-cell RNA sequencing revealed an expansion of
BEC subclusters, particularly capillary
activated HEV in AITL.
The second, spatial transcriptomics demonstrated
that among BEC subclusters,
cHEV1 was located closest to tumor cells
and formed a cHEV FDC tumor niche
together with exhausted T cells.
Multiplex digital spatial profiling validated the
spatial transcriptomics findings and further
highlighted vascular heterogeneity in AITL.
And we further found that BEC signatures were
associated with worse clinical outcomes.
These are the collaborators. Manabu Fujisawa,
he is a postdoc in BC cancer and simultaneously
staff of our department, and Yuki Shimizu, a
talented PhD student, did most of the works.
This is my final slide. Thank you for your attention, and I'm happy to take
any questions.
Hello.
It's Antonio from Ohio State University.
You mentioned briefly about integrins.
You have a result with integrins.
Yeah.
Can you tell me a little bit more about the relevance of that finding, please?
Thank you so much. Because now we analyze the functional
analysis, but we are thinking that
cHEV interacting with, I didn't
mention about the stromal cell today, but specific
stromal cells interacting and making the
vasculature structureSo
maybeintegrin or some collagen-related gene and the
protein expressed by these cells may be important, is what we are
thinking. But this is just our speculation.
We need some functional validation. Thank you so much for question.
Hello.
Yes.
Great talk.
Thank you so much.
I was wondering, you using TIM-3 as a marker for
exhausted T cells, is there a particular reason why you took
that particular marker?
Or do you have corroborating results with other
exhaustion markers like LAG-3 or any other
like TIGIT, for example, stuff like that?
Thank you so much. Yes.
We included this marker into the 40
antibodies of the
subsequent multiplex digital spatial profiling panel, and of
course, in the single-cell transcriptomics data.
Just we show to show just see the, because
the eye, we can see one color. So just we pick up
TIM-3 today, but of course, these cells express LAG-3,
TIGIT, or something. Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Dr. Suren.
Yeah, that's a fantastic talk.
So in that niche with the follicular dendritic cells and the tumor cells and
the HEV cells,
in tumors, you see these big clusters of
FDCs there, and you usually don't see individual FDCs scattered around the
tumor. So can you get at that niche just by
looking at the
shapes or the collections of FDCs without having to
do 50 markers to kind of figure that out?
Thank you so much. Because I am doing many research on
AITL, and I am thinking that FDC in
AITL distributed into two parts.
One is colocalized with B cells,
and the other part is separated from B
cell cluster. And this
part of FDC is colocalized with
so-called cHEV in forming the
vascular niche together with FDC.
So by using spatial analysis, honestly, it is difficult to
isolate the B cell
coexisting FDC because of the technology, by
dissecting technology. So now we only capture the
separated FDC in AITL,
and this is important for exhausted T cell accumulation.
Thank you so much for question.
Are there any question?
Amazing.
All right, amazing talk. Quick question.
So you mentioned those niches in particular, for example, exhausted T
cell in the close to tumor. Do you know how
they got exhausted? How tumor talk to them?
Do you know the communication between them?
Thank you so much. That is very important fundamental question.
Now we are analyzing the functional data to
enhance the why, answer the question
why. Thank you so much. We are thinking that some kind of cytokines
are very important,
which is known to promote the T cell exhaustion.
Thank you so much.
Thank you so much. So thank you so much.
The next speaker is Dr. Tse. His title
today would be Spatial
Biology Concepts
in B Cell Lymphomas.
Yeah.
Thanks a lot for the invitation to come and speak here.
So I'm a hematopathologist, so some of the things I'm going to say are going to
come from a hematopathology
perspective.
Just for disclosures, I didn't make a slide.
I have research support from Eli Lilly and
equity in Abcon Therapeutics, and none of that is relevant to this talk.
So advances in our understanding of the molecular underpinnings of
lymphomas has really largely been driven by bulk analysis, and we have the
concepts, for example, from gene expression profiling of the cell of
origin or the stromal signature or the importance of a dark zone
signature to recognize highly aggressive diffuse large B-cell
lymphomas. We've done next-generation sequencing
across multiple lymphoma types to define the mutational landscape,
and even molecular subtypes that we can kind of agree upon, for example,
in diffuse large B-cell lymphomas.
And the application of single-cell technologies really provide direct data at the
individual cell level that enable detailed descriptions of
tumor cell states, the tumor microenvironment constituents, and even clonal
trajectories.
But it's still kind of early days. If you do a
search in PubMed, I just did this last week, just wondering.
If I did single-cell RNA-seq in lymphoma, how many hits would I get?
And you get about 800. But we're here today to talk about
spatial omics and spatial technologies, and if you search spatial omics in
lymphoma, you only get about 30 hits.
So we're still really trying to figure out this technology and get reproducible
results. So what I thought I would do is just kind of review some
recent progress and some papers that I found interesting in both in follicular
lymphoma and then quickly in diffuse large B-cell lymphoma, and then really
think about how are we ever going to apply these learnings
actually in patients in the
clinic.So I'm going to start with this paper that caught my
eye back when it came out, a study out of the NCI.
It doesn't use a spatial transcriptomics or anything, but it really uses very
detailed image data to get a lot of spatial insights.
And so they came at the problem that so in follicular lymphoma,
while most patients follow an indolent clinical course, a
subset really suffer early progression and have a short survival.
And perhaps a greater understanding of both tumor cell intrinsic and
extrinsic factors governing progression and outcomes would be really
helpful.
And so a multimodal approach then could potentially identify
B-cell programs, cellular composition of tumor microenvironment, and
even topological factors like follicular and stromal features that
could predict outcome. And so they used bulk whole exome and
RNA sequencing, single-cell RNA sequencing, and then
multiplex immunofluorescence platforms to
try and identify this. And so the bulk analysis
in the figure there and the single-cell analysis is really
good at getting very detailed description of what's going on at the genomic
level, even telling us what's going on in clonotypes.
But you have to really apply these advanced imaging techniques to really get a
granular idea of what the cell phenotypes are, what the composition
is, and then really only
the imaging technologies are going to give you that kind of detail
about the relative abundance of rare cells that by
bulk sequencing or single-cell sequencing are very underrepresented, and you really
don't understand
where they are and how many of them there even are.
And so you
get that from the
imaging data. If you apply that to a series of cases of both
normal lymph nodes and follicular lymphoma with known outcomes, you should be able
to begin to get some insights.
So what they found was that in B cells in the early
progressors, upregulated B-cell receptor signaling and extracellular
matrix remodeling pathways, and that progressors were associated
with proliferative type B cells and a tumor microenvironment that was much more
capable of remodeling its stroma.
The progressors also had non-class-switched lymphoma cells
and that these B-cell intrinsic factors, along with tumor microenvironment
factors, could help identify high-risk patients.
The single-cell data characterized the lymphocytes in rare cell
populations in great detail, so things like plasmacytoid dendritic
cells that were in there, macrophage subtypes, and follicular dendritic cells.
And we noted that follicular lymphoma tissues were much more enriched in
exhausted CD8 positive T cells compared to normal lymph nodes
with molecules that were just mentioned by the person asking the previous question.
And if you apply then this relatively high plex immunofluorescence
assays, you could really begin to get a handle and detail on
diverse subsets of B cells, T cells,
myeloid cells, stromal cells,
and then really see that there are many more myeloid and stromal cells in
those tissues than you thought, rather than if you're just looking at the
single-cell RNA sequencing data.
And then what resonated as a pathologist is that when you start to look at some of
these pathways and molecules and do immunofluorescence staining, the early
progressors really had expansion of desmin positive fibroblasts, and those
are those yellow
streaks in the image. So in the progressors, you can see a lot of desmin positive
fibroblasts within the follicles.
And then DC sign positive macrophages also within follicles,
and they were seen in contact with IRF4-positive lymphoma
cells giving evidence for antigen-independent B-cell receptor
signaling in follicular lymphoma that we knew was going on, but now you can see
correlates with progression.
While the spatial data then allows you to also do community analysis, and you can
then look and
when they did that, they kind of found 15 different cellular ecosystems or
neighborhoods that they named for the dominant cell
types. And they found that the cellular communities that are seen in
normal lymph nodes are actually altered in malignancy, not surprising.
And cellular communities that were distributed heterogeneously across entities and
some were only seen in follicular lymphoma or expanded in the progressors.
And given that the extracellular matrix remodeling might be important in
relapsing patients, gene signatures associated with that fibrosis were looked
for, and the bulk and single-cell RNA sequencing data identified things
like TGF-beta and chemokines like CCL4, 5, and
CCL13 that were involved in recruitment of many different cell types
into that tumor microenvironment.
And then if you apply fancy
shape analysis of the follicles,
you could identify five different follicle types,
and applying them in paraffin tissues using sort of a
reduced plex immunofluorescence assay, you could actually reproduce
almost all of those neighborhoods that you could get with a
40 plex assay. And then really look with more
detail in outcomes and show that the high-risk patients had actually
different kind of follicles that you can see there.
So the high-risk progressors had much more kind of
disrupted follicles that were set far apart.
Again, really resonating with hematopathologists because we've seen these for
years. Most people do a follicular dendritic cell stain to evaluate
a lymph node in a follicular lymphoma patient, and we know that there are cases
certainly that have very large well-formed FDC networks that are back-to-back.
But then there are these other cases where there's almost remnant follicles, but
you know it's a follicular lymphoma.
And so those pictures really show what we've been seeing for years, but really
didn't know what the significance of that was.
And then one of the particular shapes, follicle type IV,
was seen and associated with early
relapse.Now, community
analysis also showed differences.
There's a progressive decline in communities that were
combined tumor B cells and FDC networks, and then in
the progressors in the early relapsers and then an increase in communities that
were enriched for B cells, fibroblasts, and extracellular matrix
together
were seen as well And actually, you could then make
a score, a linear predictor model of some of the most highest
risk communities, which are these stromal
communities that were enriched for desmin and vimentin positive fibroblasts
and extracellular matrix proteins, and show that those patients
that had that high linear predictor model score were
associated with early relapse. And you could then interrogate the tissues and
see those things like the lumican that you see there in yellow and
other
extracellular matrix proteins in these early relapse patients.
So the conclusions from this paper were really specific architectural features
like follicles and distribution of extracellular matrix and cellular
communities were lymphoma specific and are present actually before treatment and
really do predict for outcome.
Now, Dr. Sakata and Dr. Abe in her lab actually
focused on the T cells, and I wanted to look at this paper because this paper
really looked at spatial biology and with
the idea that we've been looking for a long time at T
cells in follicular lymphoma, but with old style tools, immunistic chemistry and
things like that. And there were papers that would come out and say certain subsets
were associated with outcome in follicular lymphoma, but they weren't really
reproducible, and it wasn't really until we could approach it from a multi-omic
approach that we could really get a handle on that.
And so they show that the follicular T cell ecosystem really
plays a major role in follicular lymphoma biology, and that follicular lymphoma
contains very distinct non-TFH follicular T cell
subsets that are actually developmentally linked, they're spatially
organized, and they're functionally anti-lymphoma and also prognostic.
So they applied single cell
RNA sequencing, single cell T cell receptor sequencing,
spatial transcriptomics using a Xenium platform, and then
multiplex spatial proteomics
platforms in formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded tissues.
And they supported those observations with functional assays that really supported
the
conclusions of that transcriptomic and spatial data.
So the single cell RNA-seq and T cell receptor sequencing data show that there
indeed were distinct non-TFH follicular T cell subsets,
namely T follicular regulatory cells and CD4 and
CD8 follicular cytotoxic cells. And these T
follicular regulatory cells, as you might expect, expressed Treg markers
like FoxP3 and CD25 and TFH markers like PD-1 and 6,
IR5. And then the cytotoxic CD4 and CD8 follicular cells
express, as you would expect, cytotoxic markers, a stem-like marker
which was actually identified in a previous paper, and then
these cells were really less aligned and terminally exhausted
cytotoxic exhausted cells. And the spatial data and the
Codex analysis really showed the strength of
the spatial data was that the TFRs and the TFHs
obviously were localized to the follicles.
And then the cytotoxic CD4 and CD8 positives cells really were
localized to the very edges of the follicles at the borders
between the T cell and B cell receptor areas.
And then communication analysis really shed light on what was
responsible for that, and that was the CXCL13, CXCR5 path,
and then the CCL19, 21, and CCR7 axis.
And so this interplay and location of these cells is very important in
the biology of a follicular lymphoma follicle.
Now, there are functional studies then that supported these
concepts. Isolated T cell subsets were shown to have
migratory competence for T follicular reg cells
towards CXCL13 gradients. The follicular
cytotoxic cells were able to produce things like interferon
gamma and TNF alpha and were able to degranulate.
And then the ability of the cytotoxic
follicular T cells to inhibit malignant B cells was also shown in
co-culture experiments.
Interestingly, the T cell receptor sequencing and single cell RNA
velocity analysis actually showed that there was clonotype sharing between all
these cells. So they were related and could differentiate into one another.
And so the T follicular regulatory cells and the cytotoxic
CD4 positive T follicular cells were really mainly derived from
Tregs and TFH cells respectively, and the cytotoxic T
follicular cells were derived from resting cytotoxic
cells that could then further differentiate it finally into the
exhausted cytotoxic population.
And then upstream regulatory analysis with differentially expressed genes
identified key players like IL-21 as a key
inducer that was supported by cellular interaction analysis and
also functional evidence to show that you could actually differentiate
Tregs into T follicular regs and TFH cells into the
cytotoxic CD4 cells, and then the naive T cell and
resting cytotoxic cells into those follicular CD8
positive T cells with IL-21 and TGF
stimulation.So now you can think about this
model and see how this kind of all works together with a TFH cell in
the kind of center being stimulated by the malignant cells and the FDC cells
to actually secrete an IL-21 and
force differentiation of Treg cells into these T
follicular reg cells that then would modulate the TFH cells and the
help to malignant cells or drive
differentiation into T follicular CD4+
cytotoxic cells or differentiating those naive CD8+
cells into these
cytotoxic T cells that would then
modulate malignant B cells. And the proof of that pudding would be,
well, then if you can quantitate these cells, which you now can with these
high-plex immunofluorescence assays and look for those cases that had
those high TFRs and TFCs, which should be
modulating the malignant cells across
multiple cohorts, you could see in the upper curves that those cases with
high populations of those cells did better than ones that had
lower
numbers of those inhibitory cells.
So the concepts from these kinds of papers, you can start to see now that there is
outcome information in follicular lymphoma that's encoded in the TMA,
the tumor microenvironment, and its organization.
It's not really only dependent on lymphoma genetic driver
genes. And early relapse is associated both with baseline
architectural and stromal features and then proportions of
lymphoma-specific follicular T cell subsets.
And that follicular lymphoma niche is really shaped by chemokines and its stromal
infrastructure,
and that the stromal TGF-beta biology is important
in follicular lymphoma.
So let's spend a couple of minutes talking about diffuse large B-cell lymphoma.
There have been multiple papers over the years using these high-plex
immunofluorescent platforms looking at cell types.
They've all been relatively smaller studies.
And I wanted to focus on the last one, which is the really, at least to my
knowledge, one of the early ones that used
true spatial tools and used CosMx platform along
with the Codex spatial imaging to look at a relatively
large number of cases and then include some other kinds of cases and really
develop a kind of a rich understanding of cell types within
diffuse large B-cell lymphoma.
So the question, this came from out of the MD Anderson group in Michael Green's lab
with the question of, can combined spatial transcriptomic,
proteomic, and genomic analysis provide a prototype understanding of
the canonical patterns of spatial organization and immunologic interactions in
large cell lymphoma?
So they had a TMA with about almost 80 diffuse large B-cell lymphomas,
but they included some EBV-positive cases and also some
large cell lymphomas of immune privileged sites, which is getting its
own play and that are going to be recognized in the new classification because they
are a little different. And so those were included in the kind of cases that were
looked at. And so they applied
the CosMx platform to do the spatial analysis along with Codex and
then had a whole exome sequencing data to kind of give the whole genetic
background and show now with that kind of data, you can really look at
there's many, many cell types within diffuse large B-cell lymphoma.
The tumor cells are green just for thing because you can reference it to these
other things. But there's many other kinds.
There's a couple of different kinds of plasma cell types and many kinds of
macrophage and tumor-associated macrophage cell types,
other stromal cells that are now defined.
And then once you understand those cell states, you can organize them into
cellular niches, and about seven cellular niches were
organized, and those are shown here.
And you can see that although tumor cells are present in all of them, there is a
couple that are highly enriched. This is the so-called CN5 niche that's
very a dense
tumor B-cell niche, and then one that's more diffuse, and it has more
mixed cell types in. As you would expect, red is the actual
T-cell, C5, in that there's a niche that's really rich
in T-cells. And if you look at the genes that are expressed there, they
make sense for the kinds of niches that you're defining.
So that detailed spatial analysis really showed that DLBCLs have
these cellular niches that do co-associate into communities, and they have
distinct patterns of cell-cell communication.
So for example, the T-cells in that T-cell-rich niche, they actually
showed increased expression of memory and naive markers and
cytotoxic markers and didn't really have a lot of exhaustion markers compared
to other niches like the myeloid and B-cell-rich niche.
So the T-cell niche was a niche where maybe they were more kind of healthy and
functional type T-cells. There's differences in T-cell proportion and
function that can be linked to differences in the chemoattracting and co-inhibitory
signals that were seen in those niches, and that the EBV-positive
large cell lymphomas and these unusual diffuse large B-cell lymphomas in these
immune-privileged site, like the CNS and the testis, have high degrees
of T-cell infiltration that are really cytotoxic, but they're also highly
expressing multiple co-inhibitory signals.
So there are these cells that are really cytotoxic but
unable to function, and that might represent then a therapeutic strategy
to deal with these kinds of lymphomas.
So when you start to think about these kinds of findings and what we're seeing from
these papers, I think it brings some questions that I have to mind.
I don't have the answers, but some observations that there's
actually sort of a kind of a not great correlation between what we're finding with
spatial data and the bulk analysis.
So I think that's telling us that that spatial data is really
bringing in a bunch of neighborhood information that was really not
considered from the bulk studies.
There's kind of not also a great correlation between the
niches and some of the genomic classifiers that we're seeing.
So again, I think the spatial transcriptomic data puts the
genomics in the context of a local tumor microenvironment, and that
that tumor microenvironment is really not entirely shaped or entirely
driven by the tumor genetics, and that there's either host factors or
given the fact that the immune system is plastic, that there is room for variation
in case to case, and it's not all preordained by the driver genes that are
present in the tumor cells.And then, are these cellular
niches lymphoma type specific that we're defining?
Or are there canonical ones that really apply across all cell types?
I don't think we've done enough studies to really understand whether we can just
think of generic cellular niches and just start plugging them
into different lymphoma types, or are we going to have to study every lymphoma
type differently, separately, because they are that
different. And then as a pathologist, I think a lot about how are we going to
scale this? How are we going to actually bring this into the clinic?
I think that is a problem. Gene expression profiling is common
in lymphoma for over 25 years now, and we're still not
great at bringing that into the clinic.
And so I think we have some work to do.
This whole meeting, I think, as you peruse different titles and sessions,
has been a meeting where there's been a ton of talk about
AI, and I think here is a question that's really quite relevant
to this problem is can we use AI tools and foundation models to
scale findings that we're learning from spatial transcriptomic
data? I think
we, along with other people, are trying to develop pathology foundation
models, and we have developed a lymphoma-specific foundation
model that we're calling LymphoVision that does
better than the general pathology models.
The only reason I bring that up is that I think
if we're going to do this, we're going to have to use
these models because they outperform general
pathology foundation models. And so if we use specific models,
we can then start to think about how do we bring them into
the spatial transcriptomic and spatial biology area, and that's
by pairing the data with those images.
And so I think there's two approaches.
These are all papers that are out in preprint, and
basically there's two approaches, right?
There's one where you can basically start from scratch, where you have paired
transcriptomic data on all your cases in the paired image
data, and you train it from scratch with image
and spatial data.
The other way, which is that last paper, the SEAL method that came out of
Dr. Mahmoud's lab at Harvard, takes a little different approach.
It starts with a well-trained foundation model and then fine-tunes
it with spatial data to make it a spatially aware foundation
model.
And they have shown that you can,
whatever task, it doesn't have to be a spatial transcriptomic task, but
once you have a spatially aware foundation model, it
does better in almost every task that you ask it to do.
And so then you could think about taking that and then training or fine-tuning it
on a true spatial prediction task.
And so these are the kind of things I think we're going to have to think about and
how we bring things like this into the clinic
and democratize the findings into something that is answering a
clinically relevant question.
And with that, I will invite you to Rochester to see our amazing Corn Tower,
if you ever want to go there. And I'll stop there. Yes, take any questions. Thanks.
Thank you, Eric. Great talk. So do you have any questions from the
audience?
Thank you so much for the great conclusion summaries.
So I'm wondering how to improve the statistical sound
of the spatial technology since the tumor can
be much bigger and each slide's only about five
to 10 micrometer, and it is relatively really expensive, and
normally the lab could just get a few slides.
And even though we say from the second paper, the "Nature
Genetics," they say the T cells have less exhaustion marker than the
B cells. Is it possible just from that one slide or they
conclude from many slides?
Yeah. So those were done on tissue microarray cores across all the things.
So I think that was an inference from across the entire set.
But your point is well taken, right?
Especially in an example like follicular lymphoma or AITL, where there's a lot
of heterogeneity across a tissue, and now if you're
basing all your analysis on two TMA cores
per case or whatever, I think you could get into some issues.
And then, of course, in the clinic, if you're doing things-- we
are doing things on just tiny little needle core biopsies, and trying
to infer some spatial data from that, I think we can also start to
run into problems.
Yes. So regarding that, is there a certain workflow
we can follow?
Like from Professor Yana Kikmoto,
and she started from the
transcriptomics data, like bulk data, and then followed a final
signature. Then we look at specific signature from the
spatial transcriptomics and validate with the spatial
proteomics. So, if we already have certain
marker that we can focus on, maybe can reduce a
bias. Is there a certain workflow you
could recommend?
Thank you for your question. I think the
bias and the pathological or
insights are quite very difficult
to discriminate is what I'm thinking.
Because I focus on-- I would like to ask
Ron and Eric because I am
focusing on angioinvasive T-cell lymphoma, because classically,
angio is very important because it is the origin
name. So there should be
something that angio-- Because when we
collect the angio proliferative sample, then it
is AITL, so it should be important, is my pathological
insight. But how we can discriminate this pathological
insight from a bias?
Sorry, I think my question was not clear.
So,
I think you made a good example, the workflow from spatial
started from the bulk RNA-Seq.
Yeah.
So we can be more focused. My question is, do we
recommend the spatial transcriptomics, the technique always
followed
after the bulk
all single-cell RNA-Seq, so we can be more-
Ah, yeah
... focused, but not just from one slice?
Thank you. For that issue,
myself, I'm confident that
we should do single-cell RNA sequencing before we do spatial
transcriptomics, because each specimen has
the thickness, so we cannot avoid
the segmentation issue completely.
So we are pretty sure that we should do single-cell RNA sequencing
before, and then we identify new cells, and we
determine the mapping. Is my stance.
How Rong is doing?
I'm not a pathologist. I'm afraid I can
not make any kind of expert recommendation, but I want to share what
Mina told me.
So often,
if you get a
fine needle biopsy,
often
she needs to order 10 IHC slides. You pretty much
would exhaust the entire tissue, and then you put a patient at
risk, right? If you don't get a good result back for those
IHC and
you cannot make a diagnosis and the patient cannot be treated, that's a
real problem. And so that's why
Mina demands, "Okay, can you get all the information from
exactly the same tissue section or adjacent, now 10 of
those,
and then I can make sure I don't put a patient at risk, and I can
get a sufficient amount of information to make a proper
diagnosis."
I think that no matter
bulk single-cell sequencing or bulk
genome sequencing,
I think
FoundationOne is
widely used, but still it got to consume a lot of tissue
specimen. I would say it depends.
So my goal is you don't need to do that, and you
get a sufficient amount of info.
But the
sampling
variability,
that's a problem I think pathologists,
oncologists, they know for decades.
You
cannot
sample entire tumor. But I know
for prostate cancer, they know how many cores you need to take to get
a relatively good representative of the tumor.
That has been investigated. I don't think
the very informative spatial omics technology is going to address
that question that has been intended to be addressed
during the past couple of decades.
But at least that single piece of tissue, if you can get much more
information, that should help, yeah, in making the whole thing
compatible with pathology. Don't
try to ask them
to take a different tissue processing protocol.
That's not going to happen.
That's not going to happen very soon, maybe.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
So it's time, so we would like to wrap up the session.
Thank you for coming.
Thank you.
Yeah. Thank you.
Fabulous talk, you guys.
Thank you.